everybody thanks for having me my
mission today is to walk you two through
a bit of code to implement a vendre in
JavaScript and as just said it's kind of
the best thing that I bounced already
does so why would we be doing this let's
say for now we just we just want to so a
bit more detail what do we want to do
today um so we want to misuse a few new
browser features that came up with html5
and stuff I want to use a bit JavaScript
to manipulate SVG HTML CSS DOM and the
CSS object model in any order so I hope
you guys have some fun on the way i
seriously had a lot of fun doing this so
um a bit more detail so what we want to
do is we want to trigger the HTML
rendering capabilities of the browser
from javascript so that basically what
the browser is doing at its best is it
just takes HTML and shows us to us in a
nice way what I want to do is get a
screenshot from a random webpage oh it's
not so random but and actually render
HTML in the canvas or in other words
basically implementing a prolly fill
which is kind of filling a gap that has
not been defined by a standards body
it's not there but I still think this
gap is needs filling and this is how it
looks like it's basically just canvas
get context droid tml that's what I want
to do it looks pretty easy does it
so let's see so those very quick
solution of Firefox gratefully offers an
API to that basically all you do is get
a canvas get the context and you draw a
window to that canvas or that's
basically what I want to do right
there's about two that it only works as
a plug-in in Firefox so if you are
plug-in you allow to you make use of
that from the web page you do not you do
not you do not go through that so you
have to you have to be a plug-in this of
course is due to security concerns so if
the browser would allow you to render a
random web page you could just go just
like painter the open gmail tab of your
user rendered to the canvas and then
read back from it and that would allow
us to get content that we're not allowed
to see so of course that is forbidden
and yeah that's not that's not bringing
us further so let's see so maybe SVG can
help us here the if you guys know canvas
the canvas does allow me to draw an
image well SVG is an image right so
let's see whether we can move forward to
that so maybe I don't know how public
that knowledge is but SVG does allow you
to embed foreign objects SVG is XML it
does allow anything it does allow other
contexts that all can also be XML and
for example it could be HTML or actually
a XHTML so the example that you can see
here i hope the font is big enough it's
basically just a strong element inside
HTML inside a foreign object in an SVG
and that is a valid image can we build
on that let's see um well first of all
what is X HTML so SVG as an XML standard
can only m-matt foreign objects that are
valid XML wall html5 goes to great
lengths of allowing you to do whatever
you want and still make it look pretty
that doesn't work well with SVG so
here's a bit of code
basically creates a document puts in
some HTML then Oh provides some XML
namespace ting and then figures the the
Firefox external serializer to civilize
that back to back to us and that is then
valid XML this does not work in chrome
and safari because basically what those
guys are saying is the external
serializer by stand by the standard only
needs to serialize xml so anyway that's
a shim I wrote for that which is
basically a hundred fifty lines of code
it's not that difficult but we need to
fall back to a pure JavaScript
implementation for that browser so a
second step needed um if I want to show
the SVG as an image i need to inline
this so the new the future way of doing
that you guys possibly have seen come
come across the blog interface so
basically you create a blob put that SVG
inside you find the time and you create
an object URL from that that's a future
last time I checked Safari is not up to
this so we kind of fall back to the
existing wave that works pretty well you
guys certainly know Delta your eyes so
we just type the whole SVG into a data
URI into an image and you're done so
yeah we can bring this together and
that's fairly simple I talked a lot but
basically that's the solution you create
a new image stuff the day URL into that
image and you draw this to the canvas
well congratulations basically um we're
done we embedded HTML as an HTML string
into a foreign object into an SVG which
we then converted into a data URI to
yield an image that we then drew into
the canvas using raw image well that
sounds all good now again but so SVG is
not allowed to reference external
resources and now it's it starts being
much more fun so if you if you draw an
SVG to the canvas all your resources
need need to be in line or need to be
present in that document you're not
allowed to link to external stuff well
that's a problem because HTML does allow
me to include images
buttons that are typed image style
sheets background images and import font
face that's a lot and that's that's all
referencing external resources that SVG
is not allowed to access so next step
what could we do to solve that and you
see it's it's all like very logical
steps to that it's getting its getting
worse by the minute kind of though I can
easily include images or buttons up in a
Type image so sorry inputs of top image
so basically all I need to do is create
get the HTML string create a document
from that so give a get a Dom structure
that I can basically just get myself all
the images iterate over those images and
just load and embed that image source
that's theory how does it look like so
um well that's an image that's an
external path external image.png what I
want to do is just replace that content
of the image as a base64 string into
that image how do I do this oh I can
load that image via Ajax right so
basically all I do is I create an xhr
request sorry xhr and wait for the image
to load and when the content is there I
I then serialize it to base64 yeah I
think the guys are just really upset my
time clock is not set correctly so or
basically loading loading the image file
HX and just piping this utilized base64
encoded content back to the image that
sounds bit easier than it actually is
Ajax does not allow sorry it just is not
allow you to load binary context Ajax
was defined to load XML which is text so
that is solved there's a new interface
you guys possibly know about XML HTTP
because to this knows about binary blobs
for last time I checked Safari again is
not up up to that so that's the easy
workaround it's one of the top-rated
answers on Stack Overflow what'd you
just do is when you get back the binary
content is kind of an awful state what'd
you just do is you iterate over each and
every bite
you and it with a white mask too but
basically cut of everything but outside
the the white field so that's a very
ugly hack it is very very slow if you
load like if you can make it by its a
big image yeah anyway but that's that's
the solution the best solution that
works right now so so basically I just
showed you how to email in line an image
using Ajax and then one doing the binary
conversion and I can now feed that back
into the HTML page using data your eyes
next step background images right you
remember the list i showed you a few
minutes ago basically all those
different kind of things background
image was number two how do we in line
background images background images all
images the problem is they are hidden in
CSS well that's pretty simple now I just
need a CSS parser to go through all my
CSS found all the background images in
line those resources just as I did
before well that's pretty simple so hey
we just want our own CSS parser for that
which then again is fairly simple so the
browser is a CS has a big CSS parser
right I mean basically a boy talking
about here's everything what the vowels
already does you just need to kind of
find a way to trigger that so here's the
power CSS method basically what it does
is it creates a style element puts the
CSS that you want to pass into that
style element and now he's a small ugly
hack you need to create a document
you're not interested in that document
but you need to apply that style element
that you created into some kind of Dom
structure otherwise the browser does not
execute the parsing algorithm so what
you do create a solemn and put the text
inside the style element put the style
element into the document and then
finally can access the past CSS rules so
that's the shortest CSS implementation
there is it's yan so you get from stack
overflow I think I answered that and
that's how you do CSS pausing in the
browser now we can put this together
again we pass CSS with the background
images we find we iterate over all the
rules if the property value background
image is
we in line that background images and
install that back into the CSS we've
done that with in with the image before
so this is just basically the same thing
with the added complexity of positing
CSS next next on the list um there are
linked elements are there with the style
sheets so what we need to do is now in
line those elements we're not allowed to
put that into an SVG the link elements
are not referenced in that SVG so we
need to inline this well sorry what what
we need to do is we need to load the
content again via Ajax that's fine then
we just put the content into a style
element and then we basically done well
not really so if you guys know CSS I
know it's jazz club but so there is the
thing that resources linked in CSS are
relative to the style sheet so if i take
starchy content take it out of the style
sheet and put it into the HTML document
the urls are all wrong so what i need to
do before pasting it into a style
element i need to go through all the
urls which is background images which is
fun phase rules and app-style imports I
need to fix this up all those URLs well
that's simple again you just need to
take care of that so here's the example
if I have a sprite.png that sits below
the parent folder and then images and
this is referenced in assets by default
CSS I need to kind of adapt that path
because now assets is basically the
offset to that so I just use the URL
pazza from from the node.js
implementation which is pure JavaScript
which is which is a very easy to include
them thanks for browsing file so it
would be nice for the browser to allow
you to do a URL pausing beside you have
to fall back to a pure JavaScript
implementation again well there you go
basically we rendered HTML through an
SVG is foreign object we in line all the
external resources by first loading
content through ajax in case of binary
content did an extra hack
we admitted images and fonts through
data your eyes for style sheets we just
pasted the whole text we passed CSS
finding resources that we needed to
adapt again is kind of a recursive
search and we adapted relative paths so
basically that's the whole algorithm
behind getting don't forget what the
initial target was forgetting HTML
inside an SVG rendered to the canvas so
yeah let's talking more demo time what
you're saying seeing here and I don't
you might not believe me so i'm going to
show you this is the title page of my
talk rendered into a canvas well it's a
bit hard to believe right could it could
have just been a screenshot I've taken
so let's switch over to I can just yep
so just say hey there and we load that
and even better to show you that this is
actually a canvas i can start shooting
my HTML and do something awesome with
that
so yeah maybe that I'll set at least one
question why why why why would you do
that that interestingly yeah I don't
know I don't know if you want to have
that on your website but it's a it's a
funny funny thing to do okay it before
you like all storm out and say I want to
do that on my next project or something
which you possibly don't but anyway
there are a few issues that you need to
know about so first of all as I said
before the browser does not allow you to
do certain kinds of things for a good
reason and here we this hack basically
does not open up a total new attack
vector all the resources that we in line
everything that we're doing is all in
the confines of the existing solution
but that means all the content that we
in line through ajax is bound to the
same origin policy so if you want to
let's say just take a screenshot of
google com well i can't do that from my
web page here because i can't access
google com through ajax unless of course
the server that you want to request with
they offer calls headers or something so
this is not a solution to take
screenshot of any pages no you're not
allowed to do that otherwise you could
be reading out somebody else's gmail
account then there's a I consider that a
bug I've talked to a few chrome guys I
chrome developers rereading from the
canvas so far is not allowed in Safari
and chrome so um firefox shines um and
the problem here is basically that
Safari and chrome have a no no I'm kind
of guessing I believe they have a kind
of simplistic approach to their sandbox
because they didn't then see somebody
coming along and wanted to do that kind
of thing they just say whatever there is
if there is a foreign object inside an
SVG you we're just going to paint the
canvas and if you want to read back from
the camels we're going to throw our
security exception so in that case if
you want to do something like that and
you want to read back from the canvas
then no sorry you're getting these three
security exception if you want to do
that firefox so far as the only solution
next issue is the IE guys
a sorry the idea are you guys are now
starting to implement for an object are
ye so far doesn't support it luckily it
did change from in consideration to in
development so hey I'm waiting for the
next IE version to come out and
hopefully we can do the same thing there
one more thing form inputs don't render
the the best implement the best
explanation that i have is well form
inputs um I kind of a kind of fall back
to what your host system gives you right
so and possibly the SVA SVG rendering
capability does not have access to that
so form improves kind of look funny a
lasting performance I did concern so it
does take a lot of time doing all that
Ajax were appalling then getting the CSS
parsing the CSS Elenna everything it can
take up to a few seconds I did consider
using a web worker for that but sadly I
do make a use of a lot of dumb api's I
don't need the actual page this is going
to but I need something and you saw the
example further CSS parser this used a
newly created document so i do need
access to that and sadly that is not
doable in web workers here's an
incomplete list of workarounds that was
needed to get all that stuff going i'm
not going to go through that a full list
this is but bit of a reference and kind
of to show you that whatever code you
guys are writing doing your day job it's
not going to be as worse as what you're
seeing here so i think i hope people
hope companies in the future will still
employ me without you know knowing that
i'm one of the worst hackers in the
world there are a few outstanding
browser issues here so some of that
things you need to work around if you
want to do stuff like that and some of
them just basically keep me from going
further and it's interestingly but
number one is Roberto cut cut
o'callaghan from Mozilla who just got me
on to that idea so he's I think from New
Zealand and he started talking about
rendering HTML to the canvas in 2006 so
he kind of inspired me to go down that
road and do that all that they
well what what is this all about it's
not not just fun I didn't sit down for
more than a year to to get that kind of
solve so this first went into a project
on github like a few different ones um
because basically I needed to implement
a full resource a inlining process there
are lot of node solutions to that but
sadly none works in the browser because
nobody is I think is stupid enough to do
that in the browser and 24 8 people on
github things it's a neat idea I just
don't know why I don't know what they
are using it for I've talked to a few
people at this conference and few people
some people actually seem to be using
HTML to canvas which is a similar
solution for finding out issues with our
webpage so if user complaints that
something's wrong they like to take a
screenshot of that page phone back home
and then they know for debugging
purposes what went wrong my personal use
case and a few of you see me talking on
Tuesday of CSS calm I want to prove that
you can test CSS and the UI taking
screenshots and that is why I basically
went down that path so thanks guys for
listening and maybe you do something
great with that and tell me about it